[موسيقى]
على جزيرة صغيرة قبالة ساحل أندامان في تايلاند ،
يقوم طاقم من الغواصين بإحضار
البضائع الثمينة على متن
هذه الأسماك ، وهي أسماك قرش الخيزران التي تم تربيتها في الأسر ،
وهم على وشك الانغماس لأول مرة
في البرية مع عالم الأحياء البحرية
كولاويت ليمشيلورات ،
وجدنا أنه حول هذا  المنطقة بها الكثير
من الشعاب المرجانية وهذا مكان مثالي
لسمك قرش الخيزران لأن هذا القرش
هو نوع من الشعاب المرجانية
الحرية لأول مرة ،
يعتبر قرش الخيزران من الأنواع الصغيرة التي
سوف
تسبح
في قاعها فهي ليست عدوانية
والأسنان ليست كذلك
أسماك القرش الحادة بشكل عام قد يكون لها سمعة سيئة
مع البشر ولكنها
ضرورية لموائلها البحرية تقول
lemchulara أن أسماك القرش تلعب دورًا مهمًا
في البيئة
لأنها مفترسة
لأنها ستتحكم في الفريسة الضعيفة ،
وستكون بيئة الشعاب المرجانية
أقوى من
الخيزران  انخفضت أعداد أسماك القرش في
السنوات الأخيرة بسبب ممارسات الصيد
وتدمير الموائل التي من المحتمل أن
تعرض الشعاب المرجانية مثل هذا
للخطر  Rals هي موطن لكثير من الأسماك
فهي تحب واحة في الصحراء تمامًا
مثل الغابات المطيرة إذا لم يكن لدينا أسماك قرش
، فسيتم تدمير بيئة الشعاب المرجانية.
القرية التي تراها
الكبسولة تتحرك ، إنها جزء من منتجع لقضاء العطلات
مع التركيز على الاستدامة ،
تأتي أجنة أسماك القرش هذه من
مركز الأحياء البحرية في فوكيت
بين شهر وثلاثة أشهر بعد ذلك ، حيث
تفقس
بينما تفقس أسماك القرش الصغيرة
هذا الرجل بعد حوالي أسبوعين فقط
من الفقس
عندما  يصل طولها إلى 30 سم ، يتم
نقلها إلى خزان أكبر لمدة ثلاثة
أشهر أخرى قبل إطلاقها في
المحيط ، كما
أن المركز هو أيضًا موطن لسمكة
اشتهرت بواسطة الرسوم المتحركة الكلاسيكية من ديزني بيكسار
لإيجاد نيمو ، يعلم الجميع أن
سمك السلور البرتقالي والأبيض نيمو
هؤلاء  يتم تربية كلوونفيش هنا
وسيتم إطلاقها في البرية إذا استنفد السكان المحليون.
rt من المنتجع ،
مركز الاكتشاف البحري مفتوح للجمهور
ومخصص لتثقيف السكان المحليين
والسياح على حد سواء حول كيفية
الاهتمام بالبيئة البحرية
، المجتمع المحلي هو الشخص الذي يعيش
هنا
يحتاجون إلى معرفة ما لديهم
ومدى أهمية ذلك  يتعين عليهم الحماية من
خلال تعزيز التغيير فوق وأسفل
المحيط ، حيث تقدم برامج كهذه لهذه
الأنواع وموائلها المرجانية
فرصة للتعافي
عندما نطلق سراحهم ، نشعر أننا
نعيد شيئًا إلى الطبيعة إذا
أعطيناهم فرصة لأن الطبيعة الأم يمكن أن تقتل
أنفسهم ،
هذا كوكب يستحق الحماية ،
أخبرنا كيف تجيب على المكالمة باستخدام
علامة التصنيف cool to earth